el cuerno de áfrica huye del hambre hay
20 millones de personas afectadas
7 millones concretamente en somalia el
doble que hace seis meses el programa
mundial de alimentos advierte
james por web conflictos grupos
extremistas junto a la temporada más
seca en décadas 45 temporadas de lluvia
acaban de desaparecer y en las últimas
cuatro décadas la temporada más seca que
hemos visto en mucho tiempo la gente
está perdiendo la esperanza tipo all we
sing out pero no sólo es áfrica estas
son las colas del hambre en haití
estas las de afganistán
50 millones de personas en 45 países
están al borde de la hambruna en 2021
828 millones una décima parte de la
población mundial ya estaba desnutrida
y realmente queremos resolver la
seguridad alimentaria debemos resolver
los problemas del agua y los problemas
de seguridad
tenemos que estar resolviendo los
problemas de pobreza también resolver
problemas con nuestros ecosistemas y
aquellos que sostienen y apoya la
agricultura en el cuerno de áfrica la
sequía se ha extendido durante cuatro
años en medio de la crisis climática la
mayoría de los lugares en los que hay
hambre también existen conflictos además
la devastación económica provocada por
la pandemia de kobe 19 y la invasión de
rusia a ucrania ambos países exportan
una cuarta parte del trigo mundial y
moscú ha estado bloqueando hasta este
mes de agosto de los puertos ucranianos
sólo en el mes de abril llegaron a subir
entre un 141 160 por ciento los precios
del agua y de los alimentos básicos